you don't believe that the  antidepressants really help the  depression whatever they do initially  feels like they're helping  but then people adapt to them and it  doesn't help antidepressant withdrawal  was the worst thing  that i'd ever experienced i hallucinated  i couldn't listen to music i couldn't be  in bright lights i couldn't function  right like it made me suicidal and the  only reason i stayed alive was because  i'd experienced that  joy of not being sick before the  antidepressant withdrawal kicked in and  was like there's a way back there i just  have to wait this out and i'm a very  stubborn person and getting on the meat  diet really helped reduce symptoms and i  don't have any antidepressant withdrawal  anymore everything is fine now but  getting off those meds is not easy